saints row gives you the ultimate
freedom to express yourself in the weird
wild west you've never seen anything
like this before so buckle up out here
it's every boss for themselves
we're gonna give you the lay of the lag
how to craft your perfect boss your
fleet of sweet rides your weapons your
crew and even your saints hq it's time
to build your criminal empire in style
people come to santo aliso from all over
because it's a place that bleeds
attitude here you do youth
in saints row show off your personal
clothing style
from shirts pants shoes and hats to full
combos underwear over wear and even
socks
it all starts at the top
customize and style every hair on your
head down to your eyebrow color
anyone can build their entire look
around anything like skin control the
type texture tint gloss scars and even
muscle and vein definition
make both sides of yourself uniquely
different asymmetrical face
customization is a burst so smear on
some lipstick add ink clown out your
face or just act your age for once
oh yeah looking real mature in those
form-fitting undies hey working on it
it's about shaping the whole package
above
envelope
but it's not just the looks that kill
pick the voice that speaks to you and
flex your mood with emotes guaranteed to
provoke a reaction from the crowd
maybe not always the one you're looking
for but hey
[ __ ] them right
the only way this could be better is if
you put on a [ __ ] shirt
[Music]
arriving style with vehicle
customization with over 80 rides to
collect you'll have plenty of time to
kill in the garage
[Music]
go deep under the hood customizing all
your rides load up on exotic parts and
pieces modify that body change paint add
grime make that engine brown
and boom a whole new boss worthy
masterpiece
[Music]
wow all that and you won't even brag
about souping up your wheels
wheels like this speak for themselves
boost performance with upgrade kicks
acceleration nitro raw speed and make
your chariot battle ready
go above and beyond with signature
abilities think boss worthy maneuvers
like crab steering make your own
wrecking ball or use ejector seats to
launch your success to new heights
you can look as slick as you want in
your customized ride all day but sooner
or
later
you're gonna need the perfect weapon
change almost every aspect of your
weapons looks adjust the material
including the color on individual parts
change textures go glossy or metallic
make it rough or smooth add decals too
if you want and looks are just skin deep
right why not swap the whole model want
to pack that rpg into a guitar case yeah
i get the reference mr mariachi
[Music]
your friends your saints your saints
vehicles they all gotta fit together
[Music]
tie the collective image into one
unified criminal masterpiece all right
listen up the church will become your go
to hq it's a real fixer-upper that you
can customize
as the saints grow in power
or dreaming one level higher head on up
to hq second floor where you can
mastermind all your criminal ventures
across the entire city
yeah looks like we can just agree to
disagree on who does boss better why
feeling overwhelmed by my outrageous
choice
[Music]
a true boss is never overwhelmed
well we can most definitely agree on
that
[Music]
you